I mean belt or really now is like it's
a major player and they have like major,
major talent. Absolutely.
Very interesting. Yeah.
I mean they don't get as much credit.
Obviously they're not those big promotion,
but they have some of the best
fighters. Yeah. They got, I mean look,
they've got gay guard sauce, you know,
they got Rory Macdonald. Macdonald. Yeah.
You can go down the list.
How about fucking Ryan Bader
Kayo and food with that crazy.
I thought Baylor was going to win.
I thought I was going to use this
pressure and just wear on him and mount
wrestling. Um, but yeah, that's crazy. 10
seconds. Well he clipped him with that.
Crazy. It's like a level chap. Yeah.
Level Change. Half Hook, Half Jab.
I think he was getting federal to think
that he was in drop for a shot and
looped to hook over the top.
Right.
It seemed like he wanted
to get fade or to do that.
Isn't that how I got the knockout? The
fight before that too, right, exactly.
And plaintiff took, yeah. Yeah.
I think it was a level change.
Left Hook and people are thinking like,
oh shit, he's coming for a take down.
What has a heavyweight man,
he's a motherfucker. I looks
good. He looks fantastic.
Body looks good. You. Yeah. I mean
he looks like a heavyweight. Yeah.
And you know he's weighing two 35
ish, somewhere around there. You know,
which is a great weight
for heavyweight things.
The best way for that weight class.
Yeah.
There's that point of diminishing returns.
Right?
You get to like two 60
unless you're in Ghana.
Well see in Ghana who doesn't know how to
wrestle. So that's part of the problem.
But, but if he did holy fuck, but as,
as agile as you need to be arrested,
I don't know if he can move that fast.
He can move fast, man. That
kind of moves like a cat. Damn.
He scares the shit out of me.
Cause like if that guy knew,
he knew like what everybody else knew.
I just think he's so physically gifted.
Yeah. I mean when you see him punch
people it's like it's a different thing.
It's different. Yeah. Just a
lunchbox coming at your head.
The power is just preposterous. Just
doesn't even make any sense. Yeah.
If that guy could get with
a guy like Dwayne and start
moving and just, you know,
not just rely on throwing hammers but set
and stuff up and switching stances and
I don't know if you can do that
with that kind of weight. You know,
like how long can a guy like that move?
You know,
that Sam can get them to move that
long. I guarantee you dude, Sam,
like I'm telling you,
like if I'm going like from my body mass,
if I'm able to walk around with
a 65 and the lactate threshold,
he's told me I can have,
I guarantee you you can do it
with the big guy like that. Wow.
That would be insane. Well, there's
not a lot of big guys like that.
That's the thing too.
It's like who does he have to train with?
It's going to push him.
Yeah. You know, the I,
that is a giant problem with heavyweights,
whether it's in wrestling
or Jujitsu or anything,
it's finding someone that they could train
with. It's that heavy. That's that big.
I mean, he's, he's a legit
natural 265 pound man. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Well, I feel like
if you're getting hit by another 200 seat,
if I'm home man two it's
going to take more out of you.
Even if a to 65 and you're getting hit
by another guy's to 65 I still feel like
your head can only take so much.